Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Hace un tiempo vengo obsesionada
contando historias de mujeres científicas.
Me encanta.
La primera que se me apareció,
obvio, Marie Curie.
No le dieron un premio Nobel, le dieron dos.
Así que se merece su pedestal.
Pero hay muchas otras que
no se ganaron un premio Nobel
pero hicieron cosas increíbles.
Hace poco me enteré de la historia
de Eugenia Sacerdote.
Eugenia era una médica italiana
que emigró a Argentina
en la época de la Segunda Guerra.
Hizo grandes aportes.
Entre ellos el más importante
fue la que trajo la vacuna Salk
contra polio en los años '50.
Gracias a ella se salvaron miles de vidas.
Yo soy científica y más o menos desde 2002
que trabajo en la universidad
haciendo investigación.
Eugenia trabajó activamente hasta el 2004
y dicen que era muy copada,
que podías ir a hablar con ella.
Y ¿saben qué? Se murió en 2011,
tenía 101 años.
Yo me enteré de ella hace muy poco.
¡Cómo me la perdí!
¡No se da una idea
la bronca que eso me dio!
Haberme enterado de ella hace muy poco.
Muchísima bronca.
Por eso yo cuento historias
de mujeres científicas.
Para homenajear a las que se fueron,
pero, sobre todo,
para no perdernos a las que están.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)